[Music]
today I'm going to talk about one of my
favorite players and he's amazing and
game skills vasily von Schuch
now what is great about vasilyev on
shook that he was on in the top 30 in
he's in the top four thirty years now
from the eighties the late 80s up to our
days he's never been out of the top 30
much and especially his famous for his
inventive play and also his strategic
and and gameplay of course so i want to
start with his game which was played in
the French championship French team
championship where he was playing
against Al chav Black was trying to be
very solid but if one choke doesn't mind
because he's looking for long-term
advantages not just slow and grinding
positions but also sometimes he'll just
go for a position where he feels that he
might get a smidge chance to win in this
position what how should we continue
with white
yeah this is kind of like a weird
structure seen in the Slav systems and
the c3 Sicilian systems a lot white has
one deep one week d4 upon while Black
has c66 weaknesses so usually in the
long term these kind of neutralize each
other but we can sense that some of the
pawns are more hanging than others which
are those pawns for black d6
so if one chip was ruthless and took
obviously now black could have taken on
h4 but that pawn is not really worth the
deal because if he takes then white
would take would open up the position
the d5 and there'll be too many troubles
one it would open up the position for
the white pieces but also this f5 pond
is going to fall sooner or later and
then most probably white will have the
better chances so dealt chef plays
Bishop d6 and not surprisingly because
this is endgame exclam the next move
won't surprise you from a von Schuch
yeah he moved the Queen from f4 to g5
yeah f4 to g5 exactly so he doesn't mind
the exchange of Queens because he's
looking for a long-term advantage she
doesn't mind all these exchanges that
dull chef is trying to force on him so
takes takes Bishop f4 Ruby one Bishop
takes g5 now there is a big danger in
this position for white what's the big
danger that he might face if not winning
is a danger
the night can be really active but what
can we say about those two bishops are
they of the same color yeah no they're
opposites so the chance of a draw is
very high in this position but classical
and top players know when it's time to
exchange pieces and when to keep them
can we tell which pawn in the near
future might become weak for white for
white yes yes so how can we get rid of
that push him yes d5 C takes d5 Knight
takes d5 rook b8 and rook b8 is a bit I
think a bit too lacks of a move think he
should have taken at least hoping that
is going to be a pose of colored bishop
bending and maybe he can hold the reason
I'm a little bit skeptical that the f5
pawn is a little bit weak and if there's
like g6 move then white can come to rook
d7 and put a lot of pressure on the
seventh rank and when the brooks start
to attack on the seventh rank most
probably black might find himself in
trouble
select didn't won that but i think still
he should have taken if there would be 8
so if von Schuch realized that aha you
want to exchange my knight Wow not
anymore
what did he play here play the very nice
move in this position
yeah and ic7 is pretty good and the
point is he really wants to have as many
pieces on the board as possible because
if flack manages to exchange off the
knights and some rogues it'll be a dead
drawn position
Knights e7 Bishop f4 Ned b5 rook f6
Bishop c4 a 694 and now we can see that
white maneuvered around so he can keep
some tension in the position and he has
real chances of winning the game because
this f5 pawn is a little bit weak the a6
bonds a little bit loose this f4 Bishop
is strong though so black also has
chances to survive
now Delta have played this knight c6
trying to get rid of this nasty pressure
on the f5 palm but Avant your calculated
further and launches into a direct
sequence of moves so why to move and
liquidate into a great endgame 96 would
not really exchange anything and most
probably black would just play Bishop e5
on a6 yes he did
very good Bishop takes a 6 and even
though this looks like a mistake because
of Knight d4 and it would be hanging
there's a sneaky little move by white
which was safe yeah
and that's what he did simple as that
he calculated that if we should not
Bishop e5 but rook takes a six and he
can just take on f4 and you'll have two
connected pass pawns
which is always a good deal so Turk
Bishop e5 rogue d5 rook takes rook takes
e5 rook takes a for loop takes f5 and
sometimes we cry that we don't have this
h2 pawn but not this time because we
don't have back rank issues anymore so
how can we evaluate this situation right
now are we winning already with white or
not yeah like as chances to draw but but
also has a little bit of a chance to win
but if on Chuck will prove that it's
easy to win this position g6 rook a3
will be for b3 now the first step is if
we follow the rules of a von Schaack
defend your pieces keep your extra pawn
and then bring your king in g7 can get
to g5 d to the King comes over to the
Queen side helping the b-pawn h5 rookie
three g4 and now black might threaten H
force but white stops at with g3 and now
this g4 pawn cannot move further anymore
and also I think apart from defending
the b3 pawn but also achieve something
in this position what did he achieve
what are the potential weaknesses in
blacks position right now
the king position is pretty bad yeah the
rook is perfectly placed defending the
pawn and cutting off the black king yes
also there's one more weakness that we
can spot in blacks position and it will
be very crucial by the end of this game
any ideas
yeah the h5 pawn is very weak you'll
have to defend it later
yeah so rugby five will be two now the
other thing that if one should often
does is defend lanes and lines before
deciding to do anything because there's
no hurry he's a pawn up there's nothing
really bad that could happen to him
right now
King f6 king c3 check oh my god it's a
check he goes back rooks see one
threatening something along the back
rank but it's not really a big threat
before black realized if he just plays
rugby one light would just start pushing
the pawn and let's say if rugby one just
be three and the pawn will just promote
Ruby five rookie for looks III who care
for check and actually we can see that
he realized okay my rook was perfectly
placed when my pawn was on b3 on the
third rank but now it's on the fourth so
I move it up maybe to okay three rook c4
so what is white aiming for now yeah
exchanging rooks because
yeah I think you didn't go but he could
have gone for a check okay three kings
see one kind of hiding away from all
these potential checks okay five and now
the move rook c5 he did succeed of
bringing the King to the Queen side
everything's in position and now he's
ready for action
Luke take c5b taxi five king of six
rookie - just after this exchange the
other rook takes it the e3 works place
it's this rook is going to cut off the
backing now okay three c6 okay seven
Roxy to c7 Kim D - keenie seven King III
and now we can see how strong this g3
move was basically like twenty five
moves ago just blocking this g4 pawn and
fixing the h5 pawn forever and now when
black would have a blockade of some
sorts on the Queen side he'll bleed on
the Kings side instead okay - eight rook
d7 got faith takes root d6 and rookie
six and black resigned because there's
no real hope of survival
cuz that Saybrook goes back we just take
the pawn rook comes we'll just slide on
up play a rope g6 and we'll just promote
the pawn very nice and clean women by
Avant shook now del Chavez obviously not
his level von Schuch is a stronger
player but even when he faces top
opposition he knows how to play these
technical positions really well here he
has played Nakamura and challenged him
in the Berlin defence that nobody really
tries these days apart from that one MV
a carjacking game that
Selam was a theoretical draw so my
camera played Bishop d7 what could be
his idea of at Bishop d7 mind you the
King already moves so it can't castle oh
he already moved the King but but but
you're correct
he wants to activate the rook but now he
one chick realizes something okay I miss
White's white squared bishop so where
should my pawn pawns be in general on
white squares or dark dark squares
obviously he should put them on dark
squares so the white bishop cannot reach
them so first he tries to get rid of
blacks Bishop there how does he do that
yes exactly here an Bishop g5 getting
rid of that nasty bishop there
Brooke the eight Knight f4 you can see
he's not rushing you can't really you're
just pin so you can't really move your
bishop away so he's not in a big rush to
exchange it off and I know this f6 move
looks tempting but this invites ideas
with night Jesus hearing on the rook and
Bishop at the same time so he plays
Bishop c8 rook takes King takes rook
Devon King g8 and then now he continues
with his strategy of putting all his
pawns on black squares g3 apart from
being a very logical move it also stops
ideas like let's say if white would have
played c3 black would continue with h4
stopping this idea of moving all those
pawns to black squares and also kind of
tying black-white down a little bit so
g3 be sure rotate 7 takes now he took
Knight g5 ok 6h for stabilizing all
those beautiful nights on f4 and g5 c5 I
should be continued
white continue yes
yeah a3 or c3 he decided to go c3 first
a5 rugby to Bishop e6 tuktuk King Jeter
now you can see this is a textbook way
of playing the Berlin defense with white
look at all those pawns on black
coloured it's placed on black color and
it's clear now that white is the one
pushing for a win and black is just
defending it's not that the position
could not be equal it can end up in a
draw but it's clearly white who's
pushing for a win knight c6 rookie to 98
I think my camera is trying to maneuver
the night 2 of 7 and just bring the King
over to c6 later on engage three knight
of seven so what would be the logical
plan for white to continue and play
which side he should be playing on yeah
obviously the Kings side but what method
he should use to show that that pawn
majority really matters in this type of
position
yeah
yeah f3g Foreman exactly that's what a
bunch of did rookie 3 f3 just getting
ready for g4 and again notice he doesn't
play f3 immediately because that would
be kind of a concession does not come
where I would be sure okay you're going
for g4 now so he plays the waiting move
rookie 3 first kind of defending the g3
square no surprises can be 7 3 B 6 a 3
again he first puts everything on dark
squares and then he decides if he wants
to play g4 or not in c6
everything's ready we can go g4 take
King takes g4 now F takes would run into
g5 ideas and that would be painful so
you didn't really want that so he took
with the king king d7 h5 so in the long
run if white really wants to win this
position he needs to create a passed
pawn otherwise it's a blockade that
black built so the only way through is
to create a passport for a1 check okay J
book d3 check another little nuance move
here by a von Schuch basically he asked
the question so where are you heading
now are you going to position your King
on the King side or the Queen side
you'll have to decide if you move it to
the Kings side your Queen side will get
a little bit weak if you move it to the
Queen side than the other side so these
little checks and ideas are very
powerful because they're kind of probing
your opponent and asking questions that
are really hard to answer right now
we'll see later on if it was a good idea
but it's not really a parent where you
should put your king the camera decided
to bring the king on the Queen side 96
you can see this night is very powerful
defending this e5 pawn and kind of
putting some pressure on blacks position
rook e8 f 4 B 5 so he wants to create
some sort of counter play on the green
side which doesn't look dangerous but in
the long run it can get really
frightening at moments a4 so that's kind
of a nice move he's trying to stop any
kind of ideas of B for a for by black
that would actually create even winning
chances for Nakamura not h6 king g5 9 f
7 King H for another precise maneuver
so if Knight f5 would happen here
he could play Knight h4 try to exchange
off this powerful Knight and then he
would most probably win the endgame
because it's kind of like a clear pawn
up on the King side but after you go
back obviously you one chip doesn't want
to draw so he plays King gauge for it
also moves out of these checks that
Nakamura was giving previously b4 c4
now you can sense that
Vasili von Schuch realized okay there's
no more like colored bishops anymore so
I can happily put all my pawns on white
squares now and also it's kind of kind
of a blockade after b3 5 plays b3 all of
these pawns are blockaded and it's
basically upon a position for white
because that extra double pawn doesn't
really do anything
9 8 16 G 5 out of 7 King G for check
King h4 knight of seven they're just
playing cat-and-mouse now
f5 he sacrifices he still wants to win
he takes a five rook d5 stabilizing the
e5 pawn because his plan is to bring the
King over to f4 later on
b3 King G 3 g5 can get 436 takes king g4
well all the black pieces are working
well the knight on d4 is amazing
the rook is well placed on e 8 the only
problem is there is no
clear way to generate a counter play in
this position meanwhile von Schuch has a
clear plan of pushing the e pawn or even
starting to think about attacking this
juicy pawn on c5 96 rook d3 i g5 check
in B 396 as you can see black is
basically waiting rook takes P 394 okay
III o p8 it was actually a clever idea
by Nakamura he gives away this b3 pawn
for active play he doesn't mind getting
rid of that because he wants to use the
beeline for his own rook rook takes B
394 move D 358 beats me but obviously
von Schuch says okay you can take my
pawn but my pawn will on e5 we'll be
able to run them King d7 mycommerce says
no no no thank you
King he for c6 Knight h4 king g6 rogue
g3 can't get 7 Knight f5 and now finally
if one chick reached his plan of trying
to exchange the knights and he made it
96 rugby 3 g5 94 and now this position
is just winning for white because after
rubgy for the king will march up to g7
and just promoted upon a very good play
by von Schuch and very eye-opening how
he again realized the strategy what he
should aim for then slowly moved up all
the pawns to the black squares and then
played rookie 3 making sure everything's
defended and then he rolled with his
pawn with f3 g 4 + h5 9 g 6 so the key
in this game was to roll slowly and just
to make sure that there's no sudden
surprises that Nakamura might have
hidden in the position alright
so that was a nice win by Avon chick and
I want to show a game which was played
in Gibraltar between f1 truck and a -
Wiktor who recently became famous after
he beat the almost 2700 grandmaster
I mean blossom from Egypt and in this
game he will put up a great fight but
then a bunch of out of nowhere will
strike me for he 6 d 4 D 5 92 this is
the classical an ID to French and a 3
Bishop d3 c5 some tricky line by black
g5 they should be one well the idea is
after g4 he wanted to play this night II
one would say if takes takes Knight d4
there's the screen takes g4 and there's
complications which should favor white
h5 Knight see to move g8 rookie one
takes takes f5 my launcher decided to
keep the position closed and because of
this 'if I've pawn his position is
slightly slightly better that f1 should
be 7 Bishop d2 at f8 f 4 B 5 a3 worship
C 397 Queen d2
slowly maneuvering and now he brings his
Knight to c5 a4 b4 night c4 he doesn't
really care about that c4 Knight at the
moment
Queen b8 night d3 green a7 let's see 5
but after he achieved his knight and
stabilized it on c5 he will be ready to
take on c4 soon and he takes on c4 b
takes bishop c2 takes takes 97 now it's
obvious it it's white who's pushing but
there's not much space left for a game
so it's very close to a drop as if white
would just play h4 g3 it would be a
total lockdown in the position look D 1
this should be 596 property for so there
tangoing a little bit having pretend
threats and now he took so in the last
minute elders had the chance to play
Bishop c6 or rug d8 to stabilize the
position to stop these sacrifices but
out of the blue
if one Chuck found rook takes d5
spectacular sacrifice he takes d5 d6 can
get six rook takes d5 why can white
sacrifice a whole rook in this position
can somebody help me with that
yeah what are the most useful pieces in
this position for white yeah the bishops
these bishops are amazingly strong this
bishop tear compensates for the rug
deficit and also the blacks King is in a
little bit of a pickle
Luke d8 takes takes Bishop f5 and the
problem is that the rook really doesn't
function well in closed positions it
rather prefer an open position and these
bishops are just happy campers why do
play Bishop C to f5 and the pawns will
start rolling just like in an endgame
Queen c7 g3 what a classy move white is
in no rush he knows that sooner or later
I'll be able to bring my bishop to C to
push my pawn and I'll just roll my way
into victory so their dish gives a check
and tries to occupy the line but then he
plays Bishop c2 and ask the question
where are you going d1 rook now if he
wouldn't do something drastic if headers
wouldn't do something drastic
f5 check would come and it would be most
likely decisive as the knight would be
taken for the check so he plays rook d3
a clever sacrifice and now after f5 we
have an endgame but it's an unpleasant
one for black because white has passed
pawns on both sides and also which
Bishop is stronger you think in this
position
yeah this dark square bishop on CT is
just dominating dingy for Bishop c6 King
e5 now the goal is for white is either
to push the F pawn or to activate all
these sleeping pawns on the Queen side
95 and now I found a brilliant move
how did
how did he break through white yes yep
he pushed upon he didn't care for the
bishop much because he could take and
there's just too many pawns it's
impossible to stop him he's seven and
even though this c4 pawn looks
threatening it's not a big deal because
it's just too far away from cleaning 97
King be 6 king be 7 out of 6 King e6 98
can get 797 Queens and black resigned
because it'll be white who Queens first
and check and if he's not in the mood he
can even exchange it and he doesn't need
to
it was just winning anyways so it's a
another great example that even in
closed positions he looks for
opportunities to find an endgame
solution that would work for him
perfectly and that reminds me of the
game that he played against Peters
fiddler in the Tom Memorial now in this
position how should white get a slight
advantage Castle well in general I kind
of realized that castling sometimes
loses the momentum exactly doubling
black bond is the good idea yes taking
on c6 because the fact is if you Castle
you might give an opportunity for black
to try something play I don't know Green
d6
and try to keep the structure intact or
take on c3 and these moments come once
in a lifetime if you Castle you lose the
momentum you might not get the chance to
ruin your opponent's pawn structure so
von Schuch says is the moment that takes
on c6 me takes c6 Queen c2 another
prophylactic idea getting out of these
route b8 threats immediately before it
would get too strong Queen e7 and now he
castles he got rid of all those threats
now he's ready to Castle c5 92 I like
this 92 because one thing he defends the
d4 pawn also he moves away from
potential exchanges because that's the
way many top grandmasters play if they
feel that they had an inferior position
they start exchanging pieces and there
won't be enough material left
to win a position like that si takes d4
Knight d4 c5 Knight b5 what could be the
idea of 95
could ya
could potentially attack the d6 square
right but also it's kind of defending
against something
what is 9b v covering with its own body
yeah it covers the b2 upon with its own
body potentially he could go a for
stabilizing the situation forever in the
queenside and this night on b5 will be
an eternal beast there that rook c8
rogue d1 and now a slow positional
struggle ensues which favours a von
Schuch
because weather is more like this active
player who really likes aggressive
active exciting play not as much
dispositional slow play now g4 kind of
inviting some complications but a bunch
of repels it aged 395 Bishop e2 you can
see how he moves all his assets back far
away from those nights he has his
beautiful Bishop there waiting to get
launched and to attack blacks position
but he moves it away at this moment
because he needs it for later on c4
sweet lyric want some action
look see one h5 night c3 Knight b6 94-95
now the two players are flirting with
the idea of draw but then a bunch of the
clients rook b8 King age one like these
wolves don't seem too meaningful but in
fact black gave this pawn but there was
a dirty trick that he was trying to hide
it's black to move and when
oh you can't move a night - beats me
yeah and half Queen takes me to
yeah exactly so sweedler was hoping for
this nice little tactic work takes me to
if why doesn't take the e to pump false
so that's bad and after Knight f3 this
is bad because you lose your queen so
you'll be sad in both cases but if once
you didn't feel like being said so you
played King H 197 would be one just
defending everything Knight c5 Bishop
takes e4 now that could have waited and
try to defend all his pawns but I guess
when they wanted to get some active play
instead of just patiently waiting for a
want you to wrap the whole game up
Knight c5 Bishop c4 Knight b6 he's
trying to exchange and just complicate
the situation we should be 595 a fourth
so even if it's not a knight on b5 this
a4 idea still works stabilizing the
situation on the Queen side
Knight a six we need to Knight B 4 so
black admitted that he didn't get too
much for the pawn but at least he built
a blockade in front of the B pond
so anytime why would start exchanging
pieces there will be always an extra
night that will jump to b4 and try to
blockade so it's not over yet Luke c1
rooks e7 Knight c3 now if once you
change his gears he's a pawn up so
exchange is good if you want to exchange
here take my knife rook c8 well then
I'll take your night he takes d5 Luke c7
Luke c7 you can notice that white is
aiming for exchanges now because he has
the bishop there and the pawn advantage
b3 Bishop sees me
why did black play Bishop's III can
somebody tell me why did he exchange or
is he why is he offering that exchange
and also the fact that white takes and
the rook takes back that night on before
will be eternal and I'm not sure that in
one ship wants that so he chases the
bishop away in f6 Queen f3
now black unfortunately for him can't
really take cuz then the rook on c7 will
be pinned and he will be forced to
exchange lots of pieces with which would
be to his disadvantage
Queenie five and now Avant chick found a
very nice liquidating move
and a really unusual one too
bishop to eat them black can still take
on e 1 and the black queen after the
exchange on c 7 will defend this way
yeah
Queen f4 it's close but if unchoke
didn't want to move this epon so he came
up with
exactly you played this very very
unusual move queen g3 this move is weird
we don't like this move in general
because it just takes one of our pawns
away from the center we usually don't
want that kind of exchange but everyone
should realize that he wants this epon
more to defend against any d4 pawn
pushes so he'd rather have an F pawn on
G 3 then this e pawn removed to f4 so
paradoxically this Queen g3 move was
more in the spirit of this position we
should be v obviously exchanges king g1
bringing the king over night c2 Bishop
d2 now black can't take on g3 because
the e5 pawn falls and it would be to
pass pawns and the bishop pair that's
just too much we should be six so sweat
there still tries and tries just to get
an opposer colored Bishop endgame but if
one chuck resists King F 2d 4b 4d 3
where should we bring our King
who says the king goes up to f3 okay who
says the king moves down to f1 f1 well
f11 and you once you did that too well
you didn't go f3 because he felt it
could get dangerous and also he might
have this knife default check so he was
trying to move away from all these
threats King f1 93 check that he take of
course not he didn't want drawn endgame
King he won Knight takes G to king d1 so
he didn't really care about that pawn
the only goal he had is to save that
Bishop on d2 and also to activate the
King on do you want h4g takes h4 now
this is always a dilemma and technical
positions whether you should exchange of
these annoying pieces of your opponent
or not I think it was a great idea to
take on h4 because in the long term if
everyone chip would have decided to play
g4 black might eventually harass this
pawn on h3 and then nobody knows what
would happen next this pawn might even
promote that an unfortunate moment so it
just takes on h4 no more trouble there
he doesn't have to pay attention to that
anymore not h4 b for now he realizes
that in end games it's not necessarily
the quantity but the quality of the
pawns that matter and after before this
a pond will be worth rooks and queens
unlike these bonds that are worth
nothing it takes before Bishop before
Knight f3
what is white need need to be conscious
of in this position what is a potential
threat
that Yvonne she needs to tread
is it a possibility that widely run out
of material yeah it is it's a true
threat in this position that why it
might just be left with two bishops
against a knight which is a win but it's
unfortunate and it takes a lot of effort
to win it so a5 Bishop d4 and now
everyone Chuck finds a very nice
maneuver which will seal the deal for
him if white pushes now then the only
way white can start pushing that pawn
again is to position the white bishop on
b8 but the problem with a6 is that will
immediately jump to a7 and there's no
way that you can promote that a pawn so
our main issue is this bishop on d4 that
is just so annoyingly active
yeah exactly some way you need to find a
way to block this Bishop out and it's a
long strategic maneuver that Yvonne she
found here Bishop to a3 what's the idea
of Bishop to a3 yes but it's not really
forcing that's the problem these six and
you Mende swish up these six and Bishop
c7 but actually he didn't play Bishop d6
but he did play Bishop e7 I'm not sure
that there's a huge difference but what
he's trying to achieve with Bishop e7
he's trying to push away the black king
of coming closer at any moment so I
really don't want to see that King do
any damage anywhere so I have five
against these wiggler's trying really
hard to exchange some pieces so it takes
takes Bishop d8 and now the bishop will
arrive on b6 which will be a real
nuisance now because black can't take it
let's say King f7 Bishop e6 black can't
take this because the a pawn turns to B
and it will cream very quickly also if
the black bishop moves away then a6 a7
is super fast again so King g6 now a six
is not a move obviously we don't want to
drop our beautiful bishop on b6 so Avant
you just found a very easy and simple
way to wrap up the game
just simple solutions here I give ya
Bishop takes Knight X
and take on d3 there's simple solutions
I really want very much like this game
by Avon church because he showed that he
was precise in the opening he didn't
Castle he first ruined swim their
structure so he has an opportunity to
play for a win and then he slowly slowly
moves his pieces back so they don't get
exchanged off and then defended the weak
b-pawn as we saw and then after that he
had the chance of slowly moving forward
when he achieved the bishop there and
when he actually got the extra pond
he started exchanging pieces not all of
them but the ones that were really not
useful anymore like the rooks
and he was just aiming to get a pawn up
and game with a bishop pair up so all in
all a von Schuch really knows how to
melt these advantages and knows that
first you need to devise a concept how
you want to attack the game like in the
game against Nakamura he put all his
pawns on the black squares and then he
slowly went forward with Luke III f3 g4
and then again he always checked of the
situation changed on the other side did
Nakamura find a different plan that
could actually alter his plan of
attacking on the Kings side now I think
you want you also kind of made
adjustments in this game against wither
he did all the things right but when
sweather sacrifices upon he switched to
exchanging pieces into instead of
avoiding those exchanges so yeah he was
up upon and then he realized that he
needs to change tactics so that's why I
advise people to
look at these games by a von Schuch
because he really knows how to win
technical and games thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]